[Music]
this story
is about this person okay let me put on
my glasses he looks like a human bulldog
russian bodybuilder russian
uh very famous in russia and uh
what part of his body does he build does
he have a maori tattoo on his arm
that is traditional sorry that is me
just noticing this is tribal artwork
that's kudos to you for realizing that
it's a maori and uh
yep yeah is he a neck guy he's like i'm
a neck guy man i only work honestly well
i will like to tell you that he's
interested it is not a he
when you're [ __ ] me okay i have been
saying
that um uh uh women that
trans transition transition into men
nowadays are way more passing than the
other way around
like i've seen like like this where you
just don't even
i'll stop you right there too because
she's also not transitioning
she is a woman and didn't transition
whatsoever she is just purely
a bodybuilder and a power lifter and she
just developed
uh her body to be this way but never
taking
any supplements no steroids of course
not
i i question that come on no dude that's
sterile those sunglasses
give it away for me it's the
hairline so when men go bald it's
excess amount of testosterone it's
nothing bad it just means you have a lot
of time i do have a lot of desserts that
means i have
very low testosterone so they say that
when men
have high tea as they say when men are
going bald it is an
increased amount of testosterone thank
you this could mean that
she has a very high amount but when you
go and add things like steroids or other
substances
even when you start playing around with
pre-workout and you mess with your
levels because it messes with your
hormones
you end up looking different i know i
had to cycle off of pre-workout at one
point in time
it messes it really messes with our
bodies and we're not supposed to be
taking it what does pre-workout do
it depends i mean it depends on what's
interesting and it depends remember um
if you guys worked out jacked
was one of the pre-workouts that ended
up getting banned because there was a
lot of substance inside of it
i used to take jack and i wanted to
fight everybody damn
i used to do ford loco as a pre-workout
that was a mistake
you're going to mutate you those gills
you wanted you're going to have them no
i ended up just drunk fighting people
did you yeah instead of working out
but it was a good workout oh yeah but
this cardio
just looks like there might be some
other things at play but hey if you just
worked out and your testosterone levels
are that high then that's just what it
is so she still
identifies as a she yes and she made
headlines recently
because she was flying uh from a city in
russia to another city in russia
and she was stopped at the the entrance
the what he called at the gate
and they didn't think that she matched
her identity they're like in your
passport it says female
you're clearly not a female and it
became an
entire hold up how dare that and they
started questioning her and they get
really into detail here they they ask
her about her
sexual orientation let me see your [ __ ]
like basically everything
but up into the point of touching and
and seeing for themselves literally yeah
they're
gonna suck on your nipples okay wait did
she
if your lippers are hard but did she not
look like her passport photo
uh is the passport photo before
the weightlifting because let's be real
if your job is to make sure that people
are not using fake identities
and it doesn't look like you're i don't
look like my driver's license but i have
to say certain things
because i don't look like it anymore
that makes sense and
since she's not transitioned she's
herself if she doesn't look like her
photo
rightfully you would be questioned
because that doesn't make sense right
but if she looked like her photo
and it would just say f then i'll be
like if she turned up
if she doesn't look like her passport
photo i understand the questioning
because
that would be like somebody stealing
their identity right if she looks like
that
and that's what her photo looks like in
her passport and they did the most yeah
let me ask you this one how far would
you pursue it though so like say
my job so it ain't for me to pursue
exactly
how about this i wouldn't be offended if
somebody's like hey are you a guy real
quick
how about that that's it no but if
they're questioning your identity if you
said i am a man
and somebody who looked at your picture
was like no you're definitely women okay
that's
different looking at it as airport
security right that's what i'm saying
i'm discriminating because she looks
kind of gangster
she looks scared so it's like what if
she stole somebody's identity
okay that's more fun but that's why i
said if she doesn't look like her
passport photo
i don't think there's anything wrong
with it but this dispels it
go ahead what if what if she took her
own photo
like like that put it on another
person's passport
and it says f right then it's
questionable because it's like your
documents are fraudulent
it happens all the time when people come
into this country they steal passports
or they sell passports that are stolen
from the states
they put other people's faces on it and
then they come in all the [ __ ] time
so i'm thinking if they're being stopped
by tsa
it's like okay yes there might be
discrimination there might be personal
like wait i'm curious right
yeah but also you have to take into
consideration that number one
i would profile someone that looks like
a gangster
too and they look like a russian mobster
to me right and then two i would
i clearly the the documents would be
like what are you doing here yeah
are you a fugitive and number three if
that if that person comes up to me
and i'm like okay it says f here but
like obviously you look like alex jones
you know i don't think that you're that
yeah and that's the difference
i don't look like my driver's license
and i know i don't because i took the
photo when i was 18
was in softball season and i was how is
this still your photo
they never told me i had to change it so
i was like forget it i look like my
passport but i don't look like my
driver's license so when i see people
look at me and kind of squint and
question and ask her and things
i know that i don't look like it so i'm
not offended which i'm prepared
for when that happens if this is the
same case
where the photo is old she should not be
quite like should not be surprised that
this is being
questioned i understand because i don't
look like that but i understand it but
the
if it's literally this is what it looks
like on her passport
yeah what was that's different results
of them trying to inquire and stuff like
did she
end up giving this airport security a
hard time or was it that they were way
too invasive
what's her reaction the way the story is
told is that
she felt embarrassed it's from her
perspective so she said she felt very
embarrassed and that
because you picture this tough russian
gangster and then they come out
and they're like i'm so embarrassed
right now what her response is actually
like very yeah very endearing and
they're kind of cute and that she was
cuz you don't picture this exactly you
look at her and she's like you got you
got you know bulletproof skin
yeah you nothing can ever hurt you
penetrate you that way you do sets with
your neck bro
[ __ ] what are we talking about but
yeah basically the airline uh
you know started asking very you know
intimate questions about her i mean i
know what she prefers in bed
and then that's the the the end of the
story is the sexual preference is never
something that needs to be asked when
it's i
when it comes do you like big dick or
little dick you're like a bigger
bigger big [ __ ] or little [ __ ]
so you say you're woman but you look
like men but do you like men or women
if you like the anal how come you like a
bigger [ __ ] that's so weird
that is so weird weird but yeah so the
end story this
she has the following on on social media
and uh
she uh tweeted at or what if the russian
version of twitter and she
got the attention of the airlines the
airlines apologized
but the damage is done uh story made it
out and
i don't even i think i'm pretty sure the
reputation of the airline took a bit of
a hit
that sucks yeah honestly they've
probably been doing stuff like that this
isn't this probably isn't anything new
we know that we're not used to that
you would never ask somebody's sexual
orientation even when it comes to their
identity
who i like and who i sleep with they got
nothing to do with what i look like kgb
is laughing at this [ __ ] i know
putin is like there's no gay people in
russia okay i don't even know who this
is like i don't i've never seen this
kind of undercover work ever in my life
speaking
of of uh nationalism yeah she says she
competes
uh trains and competes for russia and
she felt very hurt and backstabbed by
the fact that the country was treating
her this way and especially like
government agents right
tsa stuff that makes sense but yeah what
are we really expecting from them
this is not shocking but if it was here
it is shocking
don't wear a polo though what do you
have against polo shirt no no
it's like that looks very manly on
something i'm wearing a flannel
do i look manly do you you actually do
you look butch as hell
yeah i think you should be chopping down
trees not being on jk news
there we go why did you why did you just
so happen to say that right now because
there's nothing sexy about it
it's just time to chop down a tree
turning you on was not a part of today's
episode
look if you're a woman that's your job
is to be turning on a man i think we all
agree on that and i know this man thinks
that
for sure is that what you think and
that's why i love micah
i'm getting turned on right now i'm
staying quiet for this one
tim is looking at me like she gonna take
that axe and make that axe do what i do
that's why i'm i'm saying like this
because i'm like listen this is expected
it's expected the disappointment is
expected
i feel like we're here you should you
know better
you know better you stand quieter
because he knows what's happening later
what's happening later she's gonna call
nikki and tell on you
i love him don't do it no she's
threatening you
oh that's fine you know what my dick
will make it through the chopping
process
[Laughter]
that's true i heard it was like a lot of
spare you could spare like oh
yeah this is a thing no don't talk
i never talk about dicks ever so i don't
know what you guys do well you should
more
the real person is bart wanted to touch
his dick hard
yes that's that i think he revealed that
he has a really bad
gigantic enormous and bart was like oh
can i touch it
like if it was really hard but not soft
and then the more we say how big it is
the more uncomfortable he and i was like
you know
it's so now i've embraced it and i'm
like you know what bart you could double
fist it if anything
double fist you can't just touch it with
one hand he could put it in his mouth
too
so are we looking at like sriracha
bottle status
just make eye contact that's not that
big honestly this is what you're looking
at
oh he said it's not that bad we're gonna
play into it poor nicki
oh hey poor poor nicky or is
you know by the way not me that's true
or is she a true
[ __ ] come dumpster like she says she
is that's true she might
be like finally a guy that [ __ ] fills
me up
she really did say that one she she was
like
you're mine she she saw the dick and she
was like that's the one
she chose him it was the second time not
the first time ah
because the first time i was too nervous
you had stage fright yeah
big time
[Music]
you